[موسيقى]
آخر 5
سانتورو أعطوني الحفلات لكن
عندما لا تبدأ نفس اللقطة الصحيحة
الخطوات
[موسيقى]
انا اعشق
هناك في الأعلى
[موسيقى]
ثم يمكننا الذهاب
حتى في أحلام العمل منذ ذلك الحين
ماركو فون آه هذا هو الناس المفرطون
ابن
[موسيقى]
كالمعتاد من ثلاثة أسابيع إلى
التقدم الذي نجلبه في البضائع
بعد هذا العام ، كان الأمر أكثر قليلاً
معقدة لأنها في الأساس
تعمل كثيرا والمنتجات
الجزائريين لكن مع إغلاق
حدود لدينا منتجات أقل من
المعتاد والزيادات الصيد
نحن بالضرورة معقدة بعض الشيء للقيام به
فهم للناس أن هناك عددًا أقل
المنتجات وهي أغلى ثمناً هي 8
يورو في الواقع نحن نتسامح مع التسليم
يطلب منا هنا التخريد لكننا لا نفعل ذلك
لا يمكن إعداده بعد نحن
لا يوجد عدد كافٍ من الناس ولكن ليس بعد
[موسيقى]
كنا في مناخ يثير القلق
لم يرغب الناس في مغادرة منازلهم
خوفا من اصطياد
الروس grenadier جعلونا
اتصل بنا كنا هناك على
لقد كنا في السوق منذ عامين وقد كان كذلك
كانت نقطة انطلاق هذا صحيح بالنسبة لنا نحن
كان لديه العديد من الطلبات
هنا وهناك الفئات فم ذلك
المنافسين العلمانيين reynerie أو له
دربني مجموعة واسعة من
المنتجات الطازجة والجافة والمجمدة
[موسيقى]
مرحبا سيدتي نادية رجال الشرطة انه
حسنًا ، أنا سجلات المجتمع التي نقوم بها
يجدون الكتاب صعبًا جدًا
يصلون ينزلون من المحاكم
لا يوجد اتصال ولا شيء على الإطلاق
هذا أيضًا مهم جدًا لأن
أخيرًا في السوبر ماركت وجدنا ذلك
إنه حقًا غير ممكن في الساعة 7 مساءً.
لا تغلق
[موسيقى]